Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En el tercer acto de
"El lago de los cisnes",
el cisne negro lleva a cabo una
serie de vueltas interminables,
subiendo y bajando en un pie en punta,
girando y girando y girando
incesantemente 32 veces.
Es una de las secuencias
más difíciles en ballet
y durante estos 30 segundos o más,
la bailarina es una peonza humana
en continuo movimiento.
Esos giros espectaculares
se llaman "fouettés"
lo que en francés significa "azotes"
y describen la increíble capacidad
de la bailarina de girar sin cesar.
Pero, ¿mientras el fouetté nos maravilla,
podemos desentrañar su física?
La bailarina empieza el fouetté
y empuja con el pie para generar torque.
Pero la parte más difícil
es mantener el giro.
Con cada vuelta,
la fricción entre la punta
de la zapatilla y el suelo,
y la de su cuerpo con el aire
reduce su impulso.
¿Por lo tanto, cómo sigue girando?
Con cada giro,
la bailarina para una fracción
de segundo y mira al público.
Su pie de apoyo se aplana,
luego da medida vuelta, se eleva de nuevo
en punta sobre sus zapatillas,
dando un empujón para
generar un poco de torque.
Al mismo tiempo, tiene los brazos abiertos
para ayudarse a mantener el equilibrio.
Los giros son más eficaces si su centro
de gravedad se mantiene constante,
y una bailarina con experiencia
podrá mantener su eje de giro vertical.
Los brazos extendidos
y el torque de los pies
le ayudan a aumentar su fouetté.
Pero el secreto y la razón
de que todo esto apenas se note
es que la otra pierna
nunca deje de moverse.
Durante su pausa momentánea,
el pie de la bailarina se endereza
y se mueve hacia delante
antes de que doble su rodilla.
Al mantener el movimiento, la pierna
almacena parte del impulso de giro.
Cuando la pierna se acerca
de nuevo al cuerpo,
el impulso almacenado se transfiere
de nuevo al cuerpo de la bailarina,
propulsándola mientras
se eleva de nuevo en punta.
A medida que la bailarina extiende
y flexiona la pierna con cada giro,
el impulso viaja entre
su pierna y su cuerpo
manteniéndola en movimiento.
Una gran bailarina puede girar más de
una vez con cada extensión de su pierna
de una de estas dos maneras.
En primer lugar, extiende
la pierna hacia delante.
Cuanto más extiende la pierna,
mayor impulso almacena
y cuanto más impulso, más fuerza
se genera para que el cuerpo gire.
Cuanta más energía,
más vueltas puede dar
antes de tener que reponer
lo que perdió debido a la fricción.
La otra opción sería que la bailarina
mantuviese los brazos o las
piernas más cerca del cuerpo
a la vez que vuelve a elevarse.
¿Por qué funciona?
Al igual que todas los demás
movimientos en el ballet,
el fouetté se rige
por un momento angular,
que es igual a la velocidad
angular de la bailarina
multiplicada por su inercia.
Y excepto por lo que
se pierde por la fricción,
el momento angular debe ser constante
mientras que la bailarina está de punta.
Esto se llama conservación
del momento angular.
La inercia de rotación puede considerarse
como la resistencia de un cuerpo
al movimiento de rotación.
Aumenta cuando se distribuye más peso
más lejos del eje de rotación,
y disminuye cuando la masa se distribuye
más cerca al eje de rotación.
Por lo tanto, al mantener
los brazos más cerca del cuerpo,
su inercia de rotación se reduce.
Para conservar el momento angular,
su velocidad angular,
la velocidad de su giro,
debe aumentar,
permitiendo que la misma
cantidad de impulso
la mantenga girando
durante muchas vueltas.
Quizás habrás visto patinadores
sobre hielo que hacen lo mismo,
girando cada vez más rápido
recogiendo sus brazos y piernas.
En el ballet de Tchaikovsky,
el cisne negro es una bruja
y sus 32 fouettés cautivantes
parecen algo casi sobrenatural.
Pero no es la magia
lo que los hace posibles.
Es la física.